okay I think we're going to be good to
go thank you for coming along so I'm
gonna do two presentations in on end
this piece is sort of introduction to
namespaces in general or Linux what they
are what they allow us to do but then
one of the most interesting types of
namespaces is user namespaces and that's
what I'm gonna sort of drill down to in
in in the second piece because user
namespaces sort of bring all the other
namespaces together in a way that let us
do some quite powerful things things
like unprivileged containers for example
and I want to just describe how how
that's possible how it's possible to be
super user inside a container or inside
some other sort of isolation framework
while being unprivileged outside okay so
um just a little bit about me I'm the
maintainer of the Linux man pages
project I've been doing this for quite a
few years now this doesn't mean I'll
look after tens of thousands of manual
pages there is a certain project that
for historical reasons has called man
pages it provides the manual pages that
document the system calls of the Linux
kernel and see library functions and a
few other bits and pieces and there's a
bad thousand pages there and as I've
been doing that for a wee while along
the way I wrote a book and these days
pretty much my full-time workers doing
training courses and I like Norway
okay alrighty so just a bit of
background information that you want to
might want to go and look at eventually
I did write a long series of articles
about namespaces a few years back on LW
in you might find that useful look at at
some point by now I've also a bunch of
manual pages talking about namespaces
you can find them on your nearest Linux
system one other place that I like to
point people ass is a webpage written by
an engineer in California she wrote the
title in about four or five years ago
containers in five hundred lines of C
she says nowadays is a bit more than 500
lines parent it's about five hundred and
seventy CC she says I swear it was five
hundred but it's added a few pieces and
the point I want to make there to begin
with is doing the container thing you
know putting a process into a sort of an
isolated environment or on on Linux the
amount of code that you need to do that
is remarkably small the thing that makes
container systems and other sorts of
rating systems so so complex is is all
the orchestration that goes along with
it but the actual putting a process into
an isolated environment the amount of
code that's needed to do that is it's
very small so it's really hard to come
up with a simple one-sentence definition
of what a namespaces this is this is
sort of my attempt a namespace wraps
some global resource to provide
isolation of that resource Linux
supports a number of different namespace
types the the list has been growing over
time and it's about to grow a bit more
very soon I think within within the next
few months that's going to be another
namespace but for each one of these
namespaces the
is multiple I'll rephrase that one or
more name space instances on the system
when systems booted up there's one
instance of each kind of of these
namespaces and every process resides in
one instance of a particular namespace
so currently the seven namespaces each
process resides in one instance of the
seven different namespace types for the
processes that are living inside that
namespace instance they see a certain
view of some resource and that view of
that resource is private to them and if
one of those processes changes that
resource the changes are visible to the
other processes in the same namespace
but the change isn't visible to
processes that are in other namespaces
when a new name when a new process is
created that's in the same namespace as
as parents so we've got at the moment
seven different types of name place
starting with mount namespaces what
we're seeing here is a list ordered by
time so the very first name space type
was added back in 2002 the most recently
added one is 2016 and I expect I'll be
able to add ones that list still this
year so there'll be one in new in 2019
and we're seeing there also the Linux
kernel version where the namespace types
were added and these constants here
these clone new Flags these are
constants that are used in various api's
when you want to refer to different
types of namespaces system calls that
work with namespaces now you you can use
individual namespace types on their own
so going back to this timeline for
instance way back early mount LAN spaces
were aid invented in 2002 this is quite
a while before people were thinking
about things like containers and that's
because people had particular use cases
revolving just around the use of name
Mountain in space there's nothing to do
with containers so some of these names
place
you can use them on their own but often
you want to use several namespace types
together to build some sort of
application one reason is that some of
the other namespace types like IPC
namespaces see group namespaces PID
namespaces they make use of file systems
that need to be mounted and probably in
order to have the mount points not
visible to the rest of the system you
create a mount namespace at the same
time because that's what mount
namespaces do they isolate the set of
mount points seen by a group of
processes in a container type framework
you're probably using all the namespace
types together docker for example uses
nearly all of the namespace types it
hasn't caught up with c group namespaces
yet as far as I can see but I think
that's just because Dockers a bit slow
to catch up with things sometimes and
and see groups control groups are thrown
into the mix as well so it's a bit
abstract so far and I want to make it a
bit more concrete with a example of a
namespace UTS namespaces make it easy to
provide an example because they're
relatively simple in terms of what they
do and in terms of understanding how
namespaces work the idea with UTS
namespaces is they isolate to system
identifiers the so the the node name and
the domain name the node name is what we
more normally call the host name the
domain names has got nothing to do with
dns this is the NIS domain name or if
you're old enough to remember what it
used to be called the Yellow Pages
domain name it's just a system
identifier the reason why it might be
useful to isolate these identifiers is
for instance memory container
perspective you can have containers that
have different host name and different
domain name and for instance some sort
of initialization software in the
container might broadcast its hostname
to DHCP so that the container gets
assigned a unique IP address
the name UTSA comes from an ancient
[Music]
abbreviation the the the UTSA comes from
a structure called UTSA name which is
returned by the you name system call
which returns these identifiers the
reason the UTSA name structure has its
name is because this system call
returned the identifiers that were
unique for your verse your particular
instantiation of the unix time sharing
system because back then you know time
sharing was a thing it was sort of a new
thing so the original name of UNIX was
the unix time sharing system okay so on
am on a any particular linux system
there might be multiple UTS namespace
instances and within a particular UTS
namespace instance instance the
processes there will see a particular
host name a particular domain name if
one of those prices processes changes
the host name the change will be visible
to the other processes that are in the
same UTS namespace but that change won't
affect processes there in other duteous
names baseness so each suit is namespace
has its own host name its own domain
name and so we have a situation like
this branch we've got on our system
preps and I'm sorry about the
interlacing on the screen I hope you can
still read it okay
the we've got three UTS namespaces here
with some black circles some processes
inside and each namespace has its own
host name these processes here see this
host name take a poll if one of these
processes change that host name the
changes we visible just to these
processes the processes over here are
seeing a different host name and changes
over here won't affect these processes
so we've got some api's we've got some
commands for working with namespaces one
of the things we have in terms of
interfaces is
the proc ped directory there's a
subdirectory called
NES and inside that ns4 namespace
obviously and what's inside that
directory is a bunch of symbolic links
and these are kind of magic symbolic
links that give us information telling
us which namespace does this process
belong to and you can see it as well
that yeah there's one or two other sim
links in there as well but there's seven
some links that are interesting to us at
the moment and there's one sim link for
each one of the namespace types so see
group IBC Mount and so on and the
content of these symbolic links normally
the target of a symbolic link is a path
name but if you read one of these
symbolic links using say read link you
find a rather unusual string inside and
that the strings look like this some
kind of namespace name colon and then in
square brackets an inode number just
behind the scenes and you can't see this
from outside the kernel namespaces are
implemented using a file system internal
to the kernel and what you're seeing
here is the unique inode number
corresponding to this namespace that's a
sort of an irrelevant implementation
detail in a way the main point is this
number is unique for this namespace
instance so one of the uses of these
symbolic links is you can look at two
differents for two different processes
you can look at the symbolic links and
compare them if they are the same then
the two processes live inside the same
namespace if they're different the two
processes are in different namespaces
there's some system calls I'm not going
to try and drill down to these system
calls in any sort of way but just to
mention we've got clone clone is a sort
of more general version of the fork
system call it allows you to create a
new child process but at the same time
you can say I want that new child
process to be in some new namespaces and
you use some of those flags that I
showed you in an earlier slide there to
say which kinds of new namespaces shares
a bit like
it creates new namespaces but it doesn't
create a new process it moves the
calling process into those new
namespaces and then there's a system
call called steadiness which allows a
process to move itself from one
namespace where it's currently resident
into another existing namespace and the
shell commands layered on top of these
system calls there's a command called
unshare which lets you create new
namespaces and execute some command in
those namespaces then there's
InnoCentive this allows you to move into
some existing namespaces and execute
some command in those namespaces and
each one of these commands has some
flags that say what kind of namespaces
do you want to deal with so for unshare
for instance you can say unshare - lower
case you create a new UTS namespace and
there's different option letters there
to create different kinds of namespaces
and correspondingly within Ian's Center
what you can do is I want to go into
some existing namespaces one way of
doing it you say I want to go to the
existing namespaces orange from the
existing namespace the same as some
target PID so you say - TP ID and then
you might say oh and I want to go into
the same UTS namespace as their process
so you you say - you there's some
there's some privilege requirements
around creating namespaces to create
user name spaces which I haven't yet
said anything about yet much you don't
need any privilege but most of the other
lofts I'll rephrase that for all of
those types of mainstays you have a
privilege that is the caps sis admin
capability okay so this yes I'll take a
question with respect to any one
particular namespace type the process is
in exactly one instance of the namespace
now there are seven different types of
namespace but at any particular moment
you know say with respect
you tease namespaces the process is in
one UTS namespace it can't be a member
of multiple UTS namespace instances when
you say independent namespace types
independent I'm not sure UTS yes you can
you don't have to create yeah you can
create individual namespace types
independently or a namespace instances I
should say yes for some of the namespace
types that's useful to do this for
individual namespace instances for just
for some of the types but for some
others it's probably less interesting to
do so okay but you know for instance
mountain spaces which I mentioned they
were they appeared earlier on they were
invented because at that point people
only thought about isolating mount mount
point lists they weren't even thinking
about other types of namespaces the
whole container idea only emerged into
the consciousness a few years later and
then all the other namespaces started
getting added enough that sounds odd
your question or not but I would say you
want to come to the second session
because I think you think you will some
pieces will come together okay so it's
going to the demonstration so what I've
got here is two shell windows these
these two shells are in the initial
instances of each of the seven different
namespace types and what I'm going to do
up here is just just show that these two
shells are in the same UTS namespace so
I'll say read link proc dollar dollar
PID of the shell UTS oh ah but of course
yes Innes there we go
okay we see a certain number there just
yeah there's the PID of the shell and
then down here the ID of the shell and
then I say relink /proc slash Dola Dola
Dola NS UTS okay we see the same number
these two shells are in the same UTS
namespace now what I want to do then
down here is say well what's the host
name on the system okay BN
now of course the host name up here is
is the same but what I'm now going to do
is say sudo unshare - you create a new
UTS namespace and I'm gonna say run a
shell in that new beauteous namespace
all righty now if I look at the hostname
here it'd still be in now the reason is
that because when a new UTS namespace is
created it it inherits a copy of the
host name and the domain name from the
previous UTS namespace but what I could
do now oh one thing I should do perhaps
to illustrate the point if I say read
link dollar dollar UTS failing to learn
from experience I see a different number
now there this shell is in a different
UTS namespace from the shell in the
lower window so now I'm gonna change the
host name and just verify that change
okay different host name there but down
here the host name that this process
this Chelsey's is to be in okay now I
could go a little bit further I should
just echo the PID of the shell
okay one four eight zero five and then
down here I could say sudo any Center
going to some some of the same name
spaces as the PID one for like she won't
do one more thing before I do that I
should realize just to demonstrate
something else
oh yes thank you
at least someone's reading my slides
okay these two processes are still in
the same mountain namespace what this
means I haven't said too much about
mountain there so this is yet but I mean
hinting at it means they see the same
set of mount points and the point is
about these two shells they are in the
same instances of each of the other six
different namespace types they're in the
same PID a space they're in the same
network namespace they're in the same
user name space and so on they only
differ in their membership of the UTS
namespace now what I'm going to do down
here now is use the NS inter command
saying I want to go into some of the
same name spaces as PID 1 4 8 0 5 - you
go into the UTS namespace or at the same
UTS namespace as their process and I'll
just run a bash shell and of course I
need to say sudo and now if I say well
first of all let's try saying read link
/proc back up here should really just
there was the UTS namespace membership
and now can let's compare that with the
UTS namespace membership down here same
number the shell down below is now in
the new UTS namespace and now if I say
host name IC cakehole okay
now I think I've covered all that yeah
so what is this about why are we doing
it well one of the important uses of
namespaces is to do what people
sometimes call lightweight
virtualization what they more commonly
call containers when and what I mean by
virtualization is isolation of processes
putting them in their own private world
in some sense the traditional way of
doing hive of doing virtualization is
hypervisors the idea that you've got a
host kernel and right on top of that
host kernel there's a number of guest
kernels and with that sort of scheme the
processes that are running on a
particular guest colonelcy their own
private world created by that guest
kernel and it's completely isolated from
the world provided by another guest
kernel okay you just do this Firefly the
kernel and another guest kernel and you
get sort of isolation for free by having
a new kernel but also this has some some
some problems one of the things is that
you your isolation is all or nothing
either two processes are in the same
guest Colonel I see the same view of the
world well there are two different guest
kernels I see completely different
worlds and there's nothing that's sort
of halfway between when we do
virtualization via namespaces then
what's being done the isolation is being
done in the context of a single kernel
and one of the results of that is we can
do partial isolation we don't need to
isolate on all the possible dimensions
you know we might have processes that
are in the same UTS namespace and same
mount Lane space but are in different
PID namespaces for example so we we can
have degrees of ization if it suits our
application hypervisors relatively
speaking because i have to put the word
relatively in there because people pull
me up on this relatively speaking they
are simple to implement okay you've got
to architect the conversation that goes
on between the guest Colonel and the
host colonel but once you've architected
that conversation you get isolation for
free just by firing up another guest
colonel and the fact that this is these
that hypervisors were relatively simple
to implement I mean that the first
hypervisors actually appeared really
quite a long time ago happy 20th
birthday VMware and the first free
hypervisor implementations in had
already appeared back in 2003 one of the
other issues though with hypervisors is
if you want to do isolation you need to
fire another guest Colonel this is a
relatively resource intensive way of
doing isolation takes a while to fire up
the colonel the colonel needs resources
that the guest Colonel if we do
isolation using namespaces containers
this is much cheaper in resource terms
because there's only one colonel
involved we can have degrees of
isolation and but the downside is it's
much more work to implement because
there needs to be a whole lot of
refactoring in the colonel to create the
concept of separate instances of these
global resources so some of the main
space types were especially complex to
implement use namespaces perhaps the
most outstanding example of it took
several years to complete the
implementation and well it's not a stool
being implement to do the initial sort
of complete release took several years
so what are the kinds of namespaces do
we have we've got mountain lane spaces
what's being or backups in these were
the first namespace type that was
implanted a motion to command line
Colonel back in 2002 the clone flag
their clone new NS the kernel developer
back then still very much on the scene
with Linux these days so went off into
the woods for a few months and came back
and said I got this new thing I call it
a namespace and here's the flag clone
you inis okay that
point you know no one had cotton on
today that will you know we might want
to isolate other sorts of things as well
so a better name for the slag would have
been your clone new mount but its
history what's being isolated here is
the city the set of mount points that is
seen by a process and all that amount
pointers is at Apple that connects
amounts or some sort of device to a path
name and one other thing that's power
well there's a few things that are part
of the trouble but the one of the other
key things that's part of the tupple is
an idea of a parent mount because the
interrelationship of mount points the
parental relationship that defines the
single directory hierarchy that you see
so all that's being isolated by mountain
name spaces is this list of mount points
this these tuples of mount source path
name parent mount ID and this means you
can have processes that are own
different round name spaces that see a
different set of mount points and they
so therefore they say can potentially a
completely different single directory
hierarchy tree I get a completely
different set of mounted file systems
this means of course your container can
have its own set of file systems that
are visible to other containers and you
know heart necessarily visible to the
outside world either okay it means also
of course you know that many system
calls needed to change in a mount and
unmount they formerly worked on a single
global list of mount points that was
shared by everyone on the system
nowadays they needed to be retained then
they need to be refactored to deal with
the fact that they should operate only
on the mount namespace that the mount
point list of the mount namespace of the
calling process and what can we do with
mount namespaces we can have the idea of
per process private filesystem trees for
example you know you've got a multi-user
system some user logs in there's a pam
module that kicks in the pam module
create a new mount namespace mount some
file systems that user including perhaps
their home
directory and then a second user comes
along again a Pam module kicks in mount
some file system including that users
home directory so the set of file
systems that are seen by the two
different users could be completely
different and in particular they
couldn't even see each other's home
directories because the amount points
are private to the mount namespace you
can do the sort of thing that people
traditionally have done with chroot were
you confine a process to a subtree of
the filesystem but you can do it much
more flexibly with not only its basis
you can completely rearrange the view of
file systems that processes the
processes in the mount namespace is
seeing chroot of course only issue say I
want to limit the process to some
subtree of the existing single directory
hierarchy but mountain ice isn't spaces
let you completely rearrange what
processes are seeing one of the things
that's useful in the context of other
namespace types and particular PID
namespaces is you can mount certain file
systems like /proc without having side
effects on processes that are in other
namespaces so one of the that you want
to do with a PID namespace typically
which I'll talk about soon
each PID in space has its own set of P
IDs and if you want to see those PID is
in a slash proc file system you need to
mount a slash proc file system show
those pids too so quite commonly when
you creates a PID air space or for that
matter an IPC namespace or C group
namespace at the same time you also
create a mountain in space so that you
can mount the necessary file systems for
those other kinds of name space without
having side effects on the wider system
I don't know if I need to walk through
this altogether we've got as I say there
was a lot of stuff that need to be
reworked inside the kernel when mountain
air space to read it now
new mounting system calls changed but
everything that had anything to do with
path names because path names of course
are interpreted with respect to mount
points all of that code and the kernel
neat that needed to be refactored so it
was quite a big piece of work yeah now
I'm just going to mention because I I
don't have time to drill down at this
feature when mount main spaces were
initially implemented what happened was
we had the possibility of isolating a
set of mount points and you're gonna
have mini mountain name space instances
on the system and then people have to
offer after this implementation had been
done people raised actually this is too
much isolation we don't always want this
degree of isolation and the classic
example use case that is often mentioned
here is you might have a system that had
multiple mountain name spaces on it you
know for different users log in or
whatever and maybe there's an optical
disc drive on that system and you're not
you want to put an optical disc drive
into the disc and you'd like it to be
the the mounted optical disc to be
visible to every mountain in space well
in the original implementation the only
way you do that was to do a mount in
every one of the mount namespaces which
and that's what I mean by too much
isolation it would have been nice people
realized if you could just do the mount
once and have it automatically propagate
to all the other mountain namespaces so
three years later a feature called
shared sub trees was implemented and it
allows you to do exactly there propagate
mount events across mount namespaces
it's it's kind of surprisingly complex
but it does the job unless you do many
sort of quite magical things so right
what other kinds of namespaces do we
have IPC namespaces what these are about
is isolating certain IPC
I see IPC resources in particular system
5 IPC objects as shared-memory
semaphores message queues and so-called
POSIX message queues as well and the
idea is that processes that are in a
certain IPC namespace instance they'll
see a certain set of set of those IPC
objects but those IPC objects will be
invisible to a process in another IPC
namespace instance and vice-versa
so each namespace has a set of IPC
objects instead of identifiers for those
objects it has its own /dev /mq file
system which you see the POSIX message
queue objects there's a certain files
that are private and /proc and when the
namespace is destroyed then all the IPC
objects in the United space
automatically evaporate okay now I'm not
gonna talk about sea route namespaces
really because we'd need to understand
what sea groups are and either you do or
you don't but I can't do that here what
I want to say is you know see groups
control groups are you know moderately
complex pieces of infrastructure and
that makes you think that secret
namespaces must be really complicated
and not that's super simple but to
understand the way in which those super
simple you need to understand what
what's what see groups are but all I'll
say is if you're interested go and read
the secrets men our secret namespaces a
manual page and then just as an aside
I'll say all that's happening with these
namespaces is certain path names that
appear in certain prop files are being
virtualized and that's all that C group
namespaces are doing it's no it's notice
so it's really not complicated
then we've got network namespaces now
what network namespaces are doing is
isolating a whole bunch of network
resources things like routing table
rules firewall rules the socket port
number space some directories in /proc
net and sysclass net and a few other
bits and pieces and the general idea
here is let's make our containers
useful from a networking perspective we
can have the idea that each container
could have its own virtual networking
device a virtual Ethernet device a death
device and each container has its own
socket port number space so you can use
these virtual Ethernet devices to
connect the container to the outside
world there are two other containers for
example or perhaps with some NAT rules
out onto the big bad internet and then
on each container you could run a web
server on port 80
for example because every container has
its own socket port number space so what
sort of things can you do with network
namespaces well you can have
containerized network services where the
services live in their own sort of
isolated world you can do things like
instead of if you want to develop a set
of firewall rules and routing table
rules for a real physical network you
could do the sort of ladder on the
testing with real physical wires and
boxes but then you know when you get
things wrong you have to move the wires
and the boxes around potentially but
instead you could do an emulation and
software using network namespaces and do
it all in software and then when you
work out your firewall rules and your
routing table rules are all correctly
tested and working then you set up your
physical devices and wires that connect
them and install the routing table rules
and the firewall rules
there's even an emulator arm out there
that lets you do exactly this the common
open research emulator someone's already
done the work for you a lot of the use
cases for network namespaces resolve
around or revolve around security
because the thing about you know network
service if you put a network service up
there it's fair game for any attacker to
try and connect to that service so what
sort of things can you do then with
network namespaces in there since one of
the things is you can completely isolate
a process from the network when you
create a new network namespace to begin
with it has no no network device
if you've got a process inside their
network namespace then if it gets
compromised somehow it can't do bad
stuff on the network because it simply
can't create a network connection
because there's no network device
another possibility is you can have you
might have an internetwork service which
has helper processes helper processes
that live inside network namespaces and
the idea would be that the the network
service it's taking connections that
come in from clients on the big bad
internet and it passes those connections
to helper processes that are living
inside network namespaces and inside
these network namespaces there are no
network devices the helper process
inside the network namespace deals with
the client and does whatever needs to be
done but if the client is somehow a
malicious or somehow bad acts badly and
the the hell proces gets compromised it
can't create new network actions that
can't you the attacker couldn't
construct a compromise that would enable
you know the helper process to say you
know create a new network connection
cinder corporate database out over the
Internet to the attackers home base or
something
I've glossed over a little bit of magic
here because I said the help of the the
master process the master server passes
the network connection to the helper
process and I didn't say how that's done
there is a technique for doing this
it's a weird and wonderful techniques
have been available in UNIX systems for
a long time including Linux where you
can have a UNIX domain socket connection
between two processes and one process
can pass a file descriptor to another
process over there connection so the
idea would be that the master server
accepts a connection gets a new file
descriptor for a new socket which is the
socket this connect connected to the the
client passes that file descriptors of
the helper process inside the network
namespace and then the
helper prosess has that connection to
the client okay no I'm doing good for
time okay
prae no spaces now what's being isolated
here is process IDs the either is inside
a peon airspace there's a certain set of
P IDs that are visible only inside the
PID namespace they're not visible
outside the PID airspace why is this
useful well one one relevant use case we
have the technology nowadays where you
can have a container that's running on
one system one physical system and you
can sort of freeze that container
transfer across the network and then
reanimate it on another system now of
course if you were able to do that or
you can do that that container was using
a certain set of P IDs now if we move
that contain to another system maybe
some of those PID s are already being
used on that target system it's not a
problem with PID namespaces because the
P IDs are only visible inside the PID
namespace so there's no possibility of
conflict with existing PIDs another
benefit of PID namespaces is so nice a
set of P IDs and you can have a PID one
an init process and PID one does you
know some special things on any
unix-style system and it does special
things in your container one of the
things for example PID one becomes the
parent of orphaned processes and it's
usually responsible for doing certain
system initializations
piano namespaces are different from all
the other namespaces I mentioned so far
they live in a hierarchy what I mean is
each peon in space has a parent P or any
PID in airspace has a parent PID
namespace going all the way back up to
the initial PID main space there is a
maximum nesting depth but doesn't seem
to be a problem for anyone yet
next nesting depth of 32
there is an API which I'll just gloss
over the week and you that you can
actually use to discover these parental
relationships got a blog post there
about it but I won't say more now the
thing is because of this hierarchy a
process is a member of its own PID
namespace but it's also in effect a
member of the parent PID man space and
the grandparent PID namespace and all
the PID node space is going back to the
initial pyrénées PID namespace but in
each one of those levels it's almost
certainly going to have a different PID
okay
from the initial PID namespace you can
see all the processes on the system but
in a dissenter in an inferior a lower
PID airspace the only thing that you can
see the process inside that pran space
can see are the processes that are in
that namespace all lower levels the
processes and lower-level pioneer space
can't see the PID s in a high level PID
namespace picture helps here I think
okay the idea here is then we have the
initial PID namespace and again I'm
sorry about the rendering the initial PR
United States and here's our true init
process PID one and perhaps PID one
creates a new process which has PID 'the
304 using for the black arrows represent
calls to fork and perhaps that process
then uses a clone call with the clone
new PID flag to create a new PID
namespace well the very first process in
that new PID no space will have PID 1 in
that namespace but that process is also
visible on the level above where they
have some other PID maybe this process
turns around in users fork to create
another process prep which perhaps has
PID 3 again their process is visible at
the higher level where it's going to
have some PID maybe this process turns
around in users clone with the clone new
PID flag to create a grandchild
namespace the first process there has
PID one
but it's also visible at the next level
above where it has some other PID and
it's visible at the level above that
where it again has some other PID make
sense okay so when you call when a
process calls get PID what it sees is
its PID from the perspective of the
namespace where it lives so if this
process called get PID it would see one
what about if it call get PP ID any
thoughts get parent process ID I should
say any thoughts there's no visible
parent is there not in this namespace in
that case get PP ID return zero no
there's no visible parent there is a
parent but we can't see it from here
okay all right I'll skip over that now
we've got the proc pin directory that
contains the shows information about the
pids of a particular process visible in
a particular PID namespace and this
allows us to do certain kinds of
discovery so I'll just perhaps try
quickly another demo so I'm gonna say
unshare - pee-ew I'm sure - P create a
new PID namespace and I mean these
another flag that I don't want to try
and explain which is useful for with PID
namespaces and say run a bash shell
and echo Dola Dola this shall has PID 1
the thing is if I go and look and /proc
and look for all the entries you know
the big whose names and numbers - D I
just wanna see the directories not the
contents of the directories I see a
bunch of files which is weird isn't it
because as far as you know there's only
one process in this PID namespace the
reason is we're seeing a /proc mount
that corresponds to the initial PID
namespace so one of these you need to do
when you create a new PID namespace is
also renounce /proc but you don't want
that slash mount to affect the other
process on the system so what you what
we should have done was created the new
mount namespace at the same time so I'm
gonna undo what I just did there and
then I'm going to create a new PID
namespace again but at the same time
there's a credit amount namespace and
then I'll say mount - or first of all
let's look and let's look in proc again
okay
it's a mess okay just by the way we can
we can we can see that something weird
is going on if we go and look at safe
slash prop we know whether the show has
PID 1 let's go and look at /proc / 1 /
status anyone this is a bash shell with
PID 1 no see that that's system D at
system D in the initial PID namespace
okay so what I want to do at this point
is say mount oops mount - T proc source
none because this is a pseudo file
system and then /proc and now when I
look and /proc I see the right
information okay that's why I said you
often want to use mount namespaces in
conjunction with some of these other
namespaces because you want to mount
file systems where they're having side
effects on the wider system
okay that first process that PID one
insider namespace it's a new PI that fit
that PID one and the new PID airspace is
special it's the init process becomes
the parent of orphaned processes
generally it does certain kinds of
initialization so it will do some
initializations in your container for
example it's also special in the sense
PID one on traditional unix system is
special if it goes away i you know
somehow it gets killed or it terminates
the colonel says the colonel knows that
PID winner's fundamental to the
operation of the system and that in that
colin that situation unix kernels panic
and reboot the system it's a similar
situation with PRT namespaces a PID
won't one goes away the namespace is
considered to be unusable after there
all the other processes get killed and
the namespace is dead okay who's coming
back for the next hour
anyone not coming back i won't hold it
against you okay i'll just say just two
minutes thing about user name spaces but
you want to come back you for the next
hour you do and what this is about is ID
i isolating the UID now the user IDs and
group IDs the particular idea here is
you never process it since i do user
name space it has well outside the user
name space it has an unprivileged user
ID but inside the user name space it has
UID 0 it is super user inside the user
name space and it can do privileged
operations in a certain context and this
lets us do some really very interesting
things and i think i'm just going to say
if you want to know more you're gonna
have to come back in the next hour
because i've reached the end of my
slides and thank you for coming along
and if there are any questions
we took a couple minutes so is this some
sort of inheritance with mountain
namespaces I do so I think there was a
point that I go I sort of didn't say
anything about when new mountain ice
mountain ounces base is created it
inherits the mountain point list from
the previous mountain namespace so there
are there is a set of amount points
initially but then afterwards some
processes inside that mountain own space
can rearrange the set of mount points
add some remove some and so on yes okay
so if you add a new I'm sorry I should
that you continue but I think I know
where you're going yeah yeah so if you
add a new mount point in the namespace
and you add a file in that mount of file
system what's the effect and this is a
point that people often get confused
about all that amount namespace is doing
is providing a set of mount points those
mount points there might be different
mountain spaces that mount the same file
system it's the same file system the
files on that file system ah it's one
set of files so you know if two
different mount namespaces happen to
mount the same file system and one of
the prices in one file system sorry in
one mountain space change one of those
files well the change is gonna be
visible in another mountain a space
where that file system happens to be
Mountain it's only the mount points that
are being isolated not not the file
systems now if you don't want those file
system to go changes to a file system by
one mountain a space to be visible in
another manís place then don't mail bay
at file system in the other mail
namespace that's that's that's how it
works
other questions
to another yet to a helper yes yep no no
I just need to have a UNIX domain socket
connection and that's enough now they
can be they can mean different
namespaces of different types or not
that it's it's it's this is an
orthogonal technique well so people
people commonly call this technique
passing a file descriptor in reality
what's being passed is a reference to
the open file description probably you
know in layer the the sending process
might be using a certain file descriptor
number the receiving process gets a
reference to the open file and probably
it gets a file to could be allocated in
its file descriptor table it's probably
a very different file descriptor number
so even though it's called commonly file
descriptor passing it's not strictly
accurate it's a reference to an open
file that is being passed and probably
the receiving process uses a different
file descriptor number other questions
see some of you in 20 minutes
[Applause]